[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابويا واخويا انا لازم اتهم منهم
[موسيقى]
بس هم لسه
ممكن
[موسيقى]
احنا مطور العجلات الحربيه
الديسجن عندنا شبه الدهبيز
متاهه
اللي في اخره النور اللي عايزين نوصله
بين الاختيارات اللي عندنا
حواجز شبه بالظبط الحواجز بتاعه المتاهه
الحواجز دي بتمثل فيه اخطاء في الترتيب
بتتسمى عمليه
طيب الموضوع ده له تفسير يعني ليه الكلام
ده كله قايمه البايظ دي بتحصل اه ممكن
الحياه بيحصل فيه اربع حاجات اوتوماتيك
هما المسؤولين عن معظم اطعمه البايظ اول
حاجه المشكله
صعبه قوي ان احنا نخرجها او نتجاهل وجودها
يعني انا النهارده قلت لكم تخيلوا معايا
تخيلته
صعبه قوي دلوقتي
[موسيقى]
ثاني يوم نزلت ثاني ولقيت شيرت ثاني ب 80
جنيه فرحت قوي بقى
انا هنا
على الاندرويد
هي الانترك وبنات قراري ان انا جبت تيشيرت
ب 80 جنيه بناء على ان هو ارخص من اللي
كنت شوفتها مع اني كان ممكن كويس جدا ان
انا انزل ثالث يوم مثلا الاقي تيشرت قالت
ب 50 جنيه عادي يعني
ثاني حاجه بتحصل اوتوماتيك في مخك هنا انه
هو بيحب يغلي
انه لو عندي اوبشن دي انا هاختار الاوبشن
ايه ده اجمل ولا في مميزات اكثر ولا اي
حاجه من الحاجات دي ليه عشان اقصد
اللي معروض بيه فخليني اربطه انه بالنسبه
لي
وده انا الثاني خطا في التفكير اللي هو
بيتسمى الانترنبايه
يعني ده برده بيحصل في الشركات اللي هي
بتاعهم ليه هم بيكتبوا 60% فاك فري مع انه
ممكن يكتبه 40% صح هي هي 60% هي 40%
هم كده بيهايلايت اللي موجود في البودرهم
فاحنا بنبقى اشراف
في هذا كم من الدهون والتاني مش بنختار
حاجه مثلا ان هو مكتوب لنا 40% صح
ثالث حاجه بتحصل
ان هو بيحب انه الحاجه تبقى يحب ان هو
يركز على الحاجه
قدامه لا هو بيحب يشتغل تمام
يعني مثلا لو هو ربنا اكرمنا كده وبعد
عمره طويل اخذنا اجازه وقررنا ان احنا
هنسافر لبلد النعنا عشان
وانا يعني بفكر انا مثلا هاسافر
دماغي انه في بلد اكس دي لسه حاصل فيها
زلزال قلت يعني انا اكيد مش هتسافر البلد
دي مش رايحه يعني لسه قاعده اجازه
ان انا هاروح البلد
بنات بتتسمى
حاجه بتحصل اوتوماتيك برده في دماغنا ان
هو بيحب الحاجه تبقى متنامه
طيب ده اسرع على قرارنا ازاي في وقعنا في
حاجه اسمها الكونكر ماشي
لو انا مثلا مقتنعه انه في واحده مش
بتستلطفني او اللي هي مش بتحبني وقررت ان
انا يعني اكلمها محتاجاها في حاجه مثلا
وطول اليوم عماله اكلمها وهي
حامل بس
هي مش بتستلطفك
ممكن تكون مشغوله ممكن يكون حصل لها ميسي
[موسيقى]
كل اللي فات ده حاجه
ثانيه
خلاص قربنا ان احنا هناخذ القرار احنا
خلاص بقى وصلنا للنور
[موسيقى]
لو احنا مثلا ثالثه ثانوي
بيحبنيش
[موسيقى]
اللي هو الكمبيوتر
اني اختار واحد
ده معناه اني انا باقبل كتير
[موسيقى]
هيبدا ان هو يسوق كل اللي بيطلع كل
المساوى اللي موجوده في القرار اللي هو
سابه ده
[موسيقى]
ممكن يقلب القرار ويتغير قرار يعني انا
كنت مثلا مقارنه
احنا في الغالب بنعمل بالنص بنعمل حاجه
اسمها تستخدم بنبدا ان احنا نجمل قوي في
القرار اللي احنا اخذناه ونبدا ان احنا
نتسوق قوي ونطلع كل العيوب اللي موجوده في
القرار اللي احنا استناه فانا كده
كنت حاسه به عشان الاثنين كانوا قريبين من
بعض قوي ومتشابهين ما بقاش موجود واحد بقى
حلو قوي والثاني بقى وحش قوي
والحقيقه الكلام ده برده
في ناس لما كانت بتتعاقد على عربيات
وبعدين كان العربيات دي مش كويسه
عدد محترم منهم بيرجع في قراره على
العربيات توصل فبالتالي ان هم يعملوا ايه
ابتدوا ان هم
كانوا
بيتكلموا العربيه اللي هم اختاروها زيت
يعني هي مناسبه لهم وايه المميزات اللي
فيها
ولو فعلا في كميه كبيره جدا من الناس دي
ما رجعتش تتكررها وفضل فعلا مستنيه
العربيه لحد ما
[موسيقى]
ماما
على اي موضوع واحنا بنحاول ناخذ فيكم
طبعا
[موسيقى]
شباب بالضبط
[تصفيق]